[Music]
no matter how the rest of this year
unfolds you'll be able to graduate year
12 and won't be disadvantaged when it
comes to applying the University now
it's natural to feel uncertain when you
can't get all the concrete details that
you'd like but I think it's actually a
really good thing that the people who
are making all the decisions around this
of paying close attention to the
situation as it develops and will make
sure you guys are looked after however
you arrange your day I think it's vital
to have the right mindset now you could
spend six or seven or eight hours a day
studying but it's not focused and varied
then not much learning is gonna happen
try to get up around your normal morning
time get dressed
and prepare yourself for a day of
learning so the big tip here is to reach
out now while you don't get to see your
teachers in person right now you can
still fire off a question to them by
email and honestly one of the things I
miss most is the kind of interaction I
used to have with every one of my
students there are also tons of
communities of students online facing
down the same situation is used so I
encourage you to reach out to other
people around you both peers and your
teachers to give you a hand with
anything you're uncertain about I think
the key thing here is structure while
we're all self distancing you can't just
sit across from a friend in the same
room so our group studies gonna be over
the phone or through a screen so you
wanna make sure that the time you spend
together doesn't devolve into a random
chat about whatever funny video you just
watched I mean like have that random
chat but assign a specific time to it
maybe schedule a half-hour chat with a
group of friends make it short and
punchy because if you have lots of time
available that you'll fluff around you
won't use it efficiently then say make
the first five minutes to catch up with
each other
ten minutes for one person in the group
to present on a specific topic they've
studied ten minutes for people to ask
questions that you've each prepared to
see if that person really knows their
stuff and then five minutes to wrap up
and confirm the time and topic of your
next group chat assign a roster of
people to be timekeeper for each chat
and you've got a recipe for great group
study sessions
you